all right guys bang-bang see if we can
get some some folks in here and then we
will get started if you want you can
leave some comments here on the the
right side then we'll go no planning
you're not in this you will be next time
but I already get started today with a
couple of things so first is maybe we'll
go over in a few minutes the kind of
current economic situation what's
actually happening
good afternoon Ivan what's going on in
and then we can talk a little bit about
the feds response and then go over kind
of what I think will ultimately change
the situation we're in you have lots of
QE see you guys in the comments so go
ahead and leave your questions in the in
the comments here and I'll do my best to
answer as many of them as I can as we as
we get through this but especially what
we're seeing right now as I've been
talking a lot on Twitter and writing in
the newsletter is every asset price is
dumping and those asset prices are
dumping because the dollar strengthening
right and if you think about it if I
hold an asset whether it's stocks
commodities Bitcoin anything in a
liquidity crisis everyone is gonna look
around the room and say what can I
possibly sell so that I can get access
to dollars right when not everyone has
liquidity people want liquidity and so
what we're seeing is people are dumping
their assets for dollars so if you think
about it in terms of if I have one unit
of a commodity or one unit of a stock
maybe a dollar used to buy that one unit
but as I want those dollars the dollars
literally get stronger they get more
valuable and so I'm willing to sell my
unit of stock or commodity for a lower
price meaning that I'll actually now
sell it for maybe 75 cents on the dollar
or 60 cents on the dollar because I want
those dollars right so the asset prices
all draw down the dollar gets stronger
but over time what's gonna happen here
is we're going to be faced with the
decision if the dollar continues to
strain
then asset prices will continue to bleak
right that liquidity crunch will
continue to be a deflationary type
environment where the dollar is getting
stronger and the asset prices are
dropping at some point the u.s. is gonna
have to step in and they're going to
have to systematically weaken the dollar
and the reason why they're gonna have to
do this is to stabilize markets if they
don't stabilize the market all of a
sudden what you're gonna find is that
asset prices keep dropping and the
dollar keeps strengthening but when they
go to stabilize those markets they're
gonna weaken the dollar think of that as
the dollar is going to come down in
value and more dollars will be needed to
buy the same assets so if you take a
unit of a stock for example it used to
be equal 1 unit of stock for one dollar
well as that liquidity crisis happens
I'm willing to sell it for 75 cents 60
cents 50 cents etc so the dollar
actually got more valuable less of a
dollar bought that same unit of stock in
a weakening of the dollar it goes the
opposite way so all of a sudden that 50
or 60 cents I was willing to sell my
unit of stock for now all of a sudden I
want 70 cents 80 cents 90 a dollar maybe
even a dollar ten a dollar twenty dollar
34 that same unit of stock so when
there's a strengthening of the dollar
all asset prices draw down when there's
a weakening of the dollar asset prices
rise and I think part of what we have to
understand here is that although there's
been interest rate cuts and emergency
cuts there's been tons of quantitative
easing
there has been no weakening of the
dollar the dollar has actually continued
to strengthen over the last couple of
weeks
meaning that asset prices will continue
to bleed and so until we get that
weakening of the dollar asset prices
will not stabilize and they definitely
will not recover now when there is that
systemic weakening of the dollar all
asset prices should rise right it'll
take more dollars to buy the same assets
compared to today and so whether it's
equities commodities Bitcoin gold oil
whatever it is you will see asset prices
rise when that happens the big question
is when does that happen
and how do you participate in this so
obviously no financial advice today but
one of the things to keep in mind is a
lot of traders on Wall Street you know
macro traders currency traders etc
long dollars right now they understand
we're in a liquidity crisis a
deflationary environment their long
dollars when we get to that systemic
weakening of the dollar though they're
gonna flip around and they're either
going to get out of dollars so they're
gonna go into other assets or they're
going to short the dollar then the
reason is because the weakening of the
dollar will go in their favor in that
case and so I wrote last week and
basically kind of raided a bunch of
assets what I thought they would do
moving forward and you know I'll
summarize it with equities is likely to
recover over time right unless you think
America is going to fail or the asset
that you buy on the stock market is
going to go bankrupt over time they
should recover historic historically
it's shown that too was an i array that
an eight out of ten the second one was
oil I think that oil will naturally have
to rise because American shale Purdue
oil producers just can't operate at
twenty twenty-five dollars a barrel
it looks like thirty five to fifty
dollars is the range in which they'll
have to kind of comfortably be able to
turn a profit and breakeven so I think
that over time we'll see oil kind of
return to those types of levels just
because they can't operate at such low
levels and then gold I think actually is
great as an inflation hedge the problem
with gold is just that it's super stable
it's not very volatile in general and so
even when all these other assets
everything from Bitcoin drawing down 50%
at some point equities down 30 etc gold
only drew down 12% well when we flip
that around and we need volatility on
the upside and equities are rallying
bitcoins rallying etc all of a sudden
gold will rally it just won't have as
much upside so I think that it'll end up
somewhere in kind of 2020 five hundred
dollars give or take is kind of what I'm
thinking there so I rated that I think
it was like a three out of ten oil a
five out of ten equities eight out of
ten and then Bitcoin obviously I think
will do very very well mainly because
it's a highly volatile asset that acts
as an inflation hedge with that
volatility so as you many of you are
commenting in the in the comments here
we've obviously seen what I call QE
forever right which basically means
there's a ton of liquidity crisis that's
going on but at the same time I think
that there is a huge
component of when we get into that
inflationary period meaning that the Fed
is going to flood the market with
dollars they're gonna weaken the dollar
and they do that by flooding the market
with dollars making the dollars you hold
less valuable all of a sudden people
will look for assets where they do not
get caught in that devaluation of the
currency and so anything from equities
commodities Bitcoin etc will do well but
I think Bitcoin outperforms just given
the volatility that it brings with it
kind of it's a feature not a bug and
then the other example that I want to
bring up is in 2008 gold was down 30%
and when gold went down 30% 2008 it was
during this liquidity crisis right so if
you think of 2007 there started to be
some kind of warning signs 2008 was kind
of the real heart of the crisis in 2009
and ultimately their recovery tails in
10 2011 well in 2008 gold which is
supposed to be this inflation hedge and
this safe haven asset went down 30% kind
of in a six month period in the middle
of 2008 why did it do that liquidity
crisis people wanted dollars anything
with liquid market got sold but what
then happened is the government had to
respond and when they responded with
massive QE at the time about setting her
a billion dollars or so all of a sudden
investors looked around the room and
said where can I go that I can get my
wealth out of dollars which are being
devalued and get into an inflation hedge
asset which was gold and gold in the
rallying more than 3x ended up around
$1,800 announced there and so I think
similar thing is gonna happen here over
2020 and 2021 with gold and Bitcoin but
the thing that is different about
Bitcoin and gold is imagine if in the
end of 2009 and in 2010 when all of the
people are rushing to go find gold and
gold was rallying if 50 percent of the
gold miners just shut off their
operations so literally 50 percent of
the incoming daily supply of gold just
disappeared right when investors wanted
it most obviously that asset would
become more scarce it would become more
valuable supply and demand would take
over etc well that's what we're about to
see with Bitcoin right we're about to
see the fact that there was this
deflationary period liquidity crisis
everything got sold off government's
gonna respond with massive QE
when they do that I believe that
investors are going to rush for
flash and hedge assets they're going to
look for assets that are not dollars and
as they do that bitcoin will be one of
the more attractive ones given its
provable scarcity 21 million bitcoins
exist and as they're doing that in the
next 50 days or so we're gonna see 50%
of the incoming supply disappear right
the Bitcoin having is going to occur and
so as I've been saying for months and
months now you know this is rocket fuel
for Bitcoin in my opinion I really think
that the interest rate cuts the
quantitative easing and the Bitcoin
having all happening around the same
time period is a setup that is going to
be quite attractive over the next you
know 18 to 24 months for for Bitcoin so
that's where we kind of are right now a
couple of comments on the feds decision
this morning obviously they announced
kind of infinite QE or QE forever and
really the idea here is they've been
ratcheting up both in the repo markets
in their quantitative easing etc I mean
it seems like it was months ago but just
last Sunday they announced 700 billion
dollar quantitative easing plan and
their emergency rate cut to zero that
was like the big monetary stimulus bomb
that they dropped in everyone right
right before futures opened last Sunday
everyone was freaking out oh my God look
at what they're gonna do well all of a
sudden that 700 billion dollar number
500 billion was gonna go buy Treasuries
200 billion was gonna go buy
mortgage-backed securities all of a
sudden has now become unlimited right no
matter what is needed in the market they
will bring to the table and so I think
that what we're seeing here is that the
the Federal Reserve the US government
except they realize that this is an
unprecedented economic event
there's never in history been a time
where we drop an unemployment from three
and a half percent at the end of
February to what could be over 10
percent by the end of q2 some we're
estimating could be as low as or as bad
as 20 or 30 percent unemployment and
then also seeing GDP drops the estimates
are 10 20 25 30 50 percent drops in GDP
right I mean this is unprecedented stuff
and so as many of you who read the
newsletter would know last week I wrote
something about the unemployment during
the Great Depression and during the
Great Depression a lot of people say Oh
25% unemployment that's the number that
sticks out in our head the Great
Depression
and over five years so in 1929 to 1933
and during that time period the actual
math of how we got to the 25 percent
unemployment in 1933 was we started out
1929 at 3.1 percent unemployment so very
similar to what we had last year and in
the beginning of this year 3.1 percent
then jumped to 8 point something percent
by eight point five eight point seven
percent if I remember right numbers
correctly then in year two year three so
being 1931 we jumped to over fifteen
percent and then only in 1934 us two and
1933 were we up over twenty percent so
there was kind of ratcheting up with the
unemployment number that eventually got
us 25 percent what I'm fearful of here
is we're going to go from 3.5% at the
end of February to as high as 8 10 15
percent by the end of q2 if not into q3
and so that type of ratcheting up of an
unemployment number just hasn't been
seen before and then when it comes to
the drop in GDP if you think about
what's going on everyone's sitting at
home we've literally sent everyone home
and so of course GDP and economic
activity has fallen off a cliff have you
seen some of these charts where you know
restaurants for example over the last
four weeks have gone from kind of their
normal activity all the way to zero
literally zero economic activity
happening in many cities and states
around the country and then also in
other countries as well so I think
that's a huge thing that we've got to be
paying attention to where kind of normal
tools are not going to solve this
problem right unprecedented times call
for unprecedented actions and I think
that's what you saw this morning with
the feds announcement that they're gonna
have this kind of infinite quantitative
easing
now I say all that with I believe the
Fed is doing what they should do and
what they need to do to solve the
problem in the short term they really
don't have a choice we're in the
situation we're in they got to solve the
problem they gotta help people or it
doesn't mean millions of Americans out
of jobs over the next 90 days so they
have to bring as much firepower as
possible the problem is that the best
short-term solutions are really really
bad long-term solutions so I think we're
starting to see kind of how this is
playing out where there's a lot of
people saying hey let's get the
short-term help but also we
understand anytime you get into kind of
infinite money printing it's never ended
well historically and so unfortunately I
think that's you know something that
we're being set up for here but you know
it's a balance between kind of
understanding market structure
understanding their response
understanding timelines understand the
liquidity crisis but still having some
moral compass and understanding that if
this is correct right if what I'm saying
actually happens there's a lot of people
they're gonna get hurt and we need to do
as much as we possibly can to help those
people at the same time so shoot your
questions in the comments here I'll kind
of scroll through and see if I can
answer as many of them I can I'll do
this for about an hour or so plain and I
ordered some Domino's so you guys may
make it interrupted with some Domino's
here but let's see what you guys have in
the comments what does this mean for my
401k savings and checking accounts and
chase what can we do to help slow the
value from being siphoned so two things
one is your 401 K whatever assets you
hold or is gonna be the performance of
those assets right if you're in stocks
obviously whatever the performance of
those stocks are is what's gonna happen
to your 401 K hopefully you're younger
and so you kind of have time on your
side right that's one of the key things
here I think is younger people they're
learning a hard lesson right now they're
learning the importance of strong
balance sheets both at corporations but
also personally they're understanding
that cash is king in a liquidity crisis
and they're also understanding how
investments kind of affect the outlook
on their life right this is probably for
most people under the age of 35 the
first time they've had real wealth going
through a financial crisis and so I
think that that's that's important the
401 K obviously is a piece of that your
savings and checking accounts and chase
obviously I am NOT of the belief that
we're gonna have any solvency issues at
the bank currently given the data that
we have you know the dollars that you
hold are obviously right now they're
getting stronger meaning that the dollar
you own can buy more goods or more
assets because those asset prices are
drawing down over time it wouldn't
surprise me actually if when the
government acts those dollars get weaker
and so you'll be able to buy less right
asset prices will rise and so there's
kind of this weird situation where being
long dollars that's essentially what you
are by holding the
by being long dollars it's a really good
thing in the short term
once that action happens you'll start to
see some devaluation they're an asset
prices will rise again so you kind of
need to be able to navigate that if
you're asking about bank solvency I'm
not really worried about that at the
moment let's see here what else Peter
Schiff is staying away from the dollar
yeah so exactly what I'm talk about here
I think Peter and I actually agree right
now the dollar strengthening but it's
gonna be a short-term thing right so if
you're a currency trader or a macro
trader and you want to kind of get in
and get some short-term profits going
long dollar with leverage all that kind
of stuff that's what those folks are
doing but very quickly here as we get
the quantitative easing etc the dollar
will be devalued what ends up happening
is a lot of those currency traders and
macro traders are actually gonna flip
around don't short the dollar they'll go
long go long bitcoin you know long other
assets because most other asset prices
will rise so they're kind of long dollar
short term they'll flip around when we
get that quantitative easing so I think
over a long period of time for most
people who are not traders staying away
from the dollar it's actually probably a
pretty good way to look at it I'm not
gonna talk so much about Bitcoin price I
don't think that really matters that
much I love the gold commercials Jason
yeah look everybody is is the same right
and I think that here's the crazy part
is a lot of the golden bugs were right
in kind of the 2008 crisis they saw the
asset reach all-time highs and in the
quantitative easing theory kind of
played out there I think they're gonna
be right again obviously part of the
problem is that in the years in between
these crisis they kind of just have
stability right and they kind of may get
some fluctuations here and there but for
the most part just too stable assets
great savings tool etc I do think that
gold will perform well during this
financial crisis Early's coming out of
the financial crisis as the quantitative
easing solutions get introduced i think
bitcoin will do the same
I'm just of the belief that the coin is
more volatility so it draws down more in
liquidity crisis it will actually
outperform drastically in in kind of
recovery you know I'm on record as
saying I think bitcoin will be the best
performing asset coming out of the
financial crisis and so obviously my
portfolio kind of reflects that when
does this start when does this start
hurting the housing
market when borrowers begin defaulting
what is likely soon what happens I don't
Patel so yeah I think that this is not
just housing is also true commercial
real estate in other places what you
have to understand kind of what I wrote
about this morning is this what I call
the economic circle of life which in
let's take the corporate market first so
you've got material producers those
material producers basically give the
materials to suppliers suppliers take a
bunch of materials and they create a
product they that the supplier then
sells that product to the business the
business then sells it to consumers that
business takes part of their revenue
they pay rent to a landlord that
landlord then pays part of that rent to
bank who help them finance the purchase
of the building so you kind of get this
circular action well when there's a
break in the circle of economic life
meaning the business is shut down all of
a sudden you get upstream and downstream
damage right so the upstream damage
meaning that all of a sudden the
supplier doesn't have a business to sell
the products to and the materials
producer can't actually get it to the
supplier because there's no throughput
what you get is almost like a dam in a
river so the business shuts down now you
have the supplier left holding a bunch
of products they can't offload and they
can't reorder any more materials because
they don't have any demand for it so you
kind of get this stuff äj-- or literally
the dam in the river everything above
the dam just gets blocked up until you
the dam is released or it gets so
overwhelming that it goes over the dam
right so I think that's what's happening
kind of upstream you see like in
restaurants all of their suppliers etc
just left holding food because the
restaurant shuts down now that's pretty
easily explainable the downstream damage
is actually really really important
though so let's say that you are that
restaurant or some business and you've
got rent Lots a fixed cost for your
business and so you can probably
actually eat into your profit margin
let's say you you're operating a
restaurant at ten percent margin and you
continue to have kind of steady revenue
you've got all of your fixed costs all
your variable cost paid and you get ten
percent profit
well if revenue drops ten percent you
actually probably still could pay your
fixed and variable cost and you just
wouldn't make no profit but the second
that your revenue goes to zero you don't
have enough cash think the average small
business has like 17 days or 27 days of
cash
in their bank and so you just can't pay
your rent so April first comes how do
you pay your rent right and I think
that's where you're getting landlords
that are saying look I would love to
give rent abatement or give concessions
but I can't because the bank won't give
me any sort of concession it's right I
owe money to the bank so I can't let you
not paying I can't pay and so you get in
this weird world where there's got to be
either concessions that are made from
the bank level down to the landlord who
then passes that on to kind of the
tenant or you've got to have the
government step in and the government is
going to give capital to that small
business so they can pay for for the
rent but I think whether it's the
corporate market or the kind of retail
or housing market what you're gonna see
is is a liquidity crunch and however
long this liquidity crunch lasts the
deeper we get into it the more people
will have to sell assets right they just
need liquidity and so I don't think
right now prices are really reflecting
that kind of people are still wrapping
their head around the fact we're in a
liquidity crisis but very shortly here
it wouldn't surprise me to see home
prices dropping to see kind of corporate
real estate prices dropping etc mainly
because people are forced sellers right
they they don't have anything they're
motivated sellers they don't have other
options they're gonna take whatever the
market will give them and because the
dollar is so strong or so sought-after
they're gonna have to actually take less
dollars in order to sell that property
so I think over time we'll go ahead and
we'll see the housing market affected if
the liquidity crisis lasts long enough
that's the big question how long will
last is that another month is it three
months six months nobody knows yet but I
think that's the big thing to watch
there let's see here well governments
change the goalposts I don't really
understand that question so if you want
just replay with it and I'll see if I
can do it again when we hit 40%
unemployment will the hundred gamester
look unemployment's real right you know
it there's the saying like if you want
to see what humans are really made of
don't feed them for three days right and
I think that that that's a very real you
know kind of truth which is people have
to eat people have to protect their
families people have to do things in the
world and they need jobs in order to be
able to fund those activities and so
what ends up happening here is if we get
to high levels of unemployment you know
20
percent I think that we're gonna see
quite a bit of social unrest quite a bit
of violence etc so you know my hope is
that we never get close to that stuff
because again that there's kind of the
truth behind all of this there's the
monetary policy stuff there's the fiscal
policy stuff but there's real American
lives and and all over the world not
just Americans right all over the world
people are being hurt families are in
jeopardy you know people are losing
their businesses to actually fund kind
of the income for their families and so
this is real stuff right and we really
need to to kind of take a serious look
at how do we solve these problems
because again forty percent unemployment
would not be pretty from a social unrest
standpoint let's see what else
silver stocks I put silver and gold in
the same category I don't know enough
about silver to kind of decipher between
the two so I won't really comment there
why is Bitcoin not skyrocketing okay
this is a really good important question
so everyone's like oh my god they
announced all this QE why didn't Bitcoin
just you know triple overnight and we
have to remember is that we're still a
little acquitted E crisis right that's
why they're announcing the QE so you
don't expect over or you know overnight
for a Bitcoin to go from being affected
by the liquidity crisis where it's sold
off you know up to 50% now sitting about
30% down and then immediately just
triple instead of what you're likely to
see is exactly what just happened we're
in a liquidity crisis but Bitcoin is
either staying flat or up a couple a
hundred basis points rights up like two
three six percent whatever it ends up
being on each day while it's up you know
one to five one to six percent each day
other assets are selling off them
equities are down you know two or three
percent etc and so you're actually
seeing kind of a decoupling of Bitcoin
and these other assets we're still in a
liquidity crisis so you're not gonna see
any violent moves to the upside but what
you are seeing is kind of this belief
that people are not willing to sell a
Bitcoin for example in this environment
for dollars right that's why you get
either flat or a little up right it's
actually net buyers or just net holders
you don't get net selling because they
understand the environment that we're in
yes its deflationary right now but we're
headed into an inflationary period and
in that period gold Bitcoin exception
will be super valuable to hold so I
think that's why you
not skyrocketing but it's kind of
holding really really steady and
continuing to kind of be flat to up when
other assets are you know pretty much
down but not down significantly
although on on Friday there we saw some
pretty violent moves to the downside and
equities I think that's kind of the way
to think about that let's see what else
here Bitcoin wasn't built to withstand a
pandemic yeah I would basically say
Bitcoin is built to withstand everything
right here's the crazy part about all of
this is that while the world is
literally appears or people feel like
it's ending literally everything is
gonna fall apart etc if you notice
Bitcoin continues to produce block after
block after block after block nobody is
worried about what is Bitcoin going to
do right is it gonna produce the next
block of course it's going to do that
and then also while that's happening
there's no response
Bitcoin doesn't care what's going on in
the world nobody's calling up the
Bitcoin CEO and say hey what do you
think about what's going on are you
gonna fire any employees are you gonna
change your monetary policy no it just
continues to do what it's supposed to do
and over a long period of time having
the consistency and discipline of a
programmatic monetary policy I believe
will be superior to what we're seeing in
nutritional markets right and kind of
traditional fiat currencies it's
absolute chaos if you think about what's
happening right now we literally have a
currency that is being manipulated more
than we've ever seen and we're seeing
announcements for infinite quantitative
easing this is the greatest monetary
stimulus experiment that the world has
ever seen and the bills behind how much
goes to who is being held up by by
parson aura bipartisan politics right
we've got a bunch of people who are
going into a room and they're
negotiating and if you see the things
that are negotiating about it's absolute
chaos right both sides are to blame and
if they really wanted to help the
American people and the American
businesses what they should do is go
into a room and get a deal done and not
worry so much about who got the latest
you know best thing done or who got
their agenda accomplished etc instead go
help the American people go help
American businesses and so I think that
unfortunately what we're seeing right
now there's a lot of people being hurt
but we're seeing the difference between
the
Bitcoin monetary policy and the Fiat
monetary policy the Fiat monetary policy
is absolutely freaking out
they have lost control they have no clue
what is going on they keep firing
bullets and they keep not working right
this morning we literally had infinite
quantitative easing announced and the
public markets are down how does that
happen
infinite quantitative easing public
markets are down Bitcoin flat - up right
so what you're starting to see again is
that programmatic kind of monetary
policy is gonna be really really
important the more chaotic the world
gets the more dependable it appears that
bitcoin is people will start to realize
hey there's value in that I want
consistency
I want that dependability and therefore
they'll start - it'll start to earn the
trust of people in this chaotic
environment Britain just sheltered in
place and forced by police why hasn't
this happened in the US I don't even
know if that's true or not but if it is
obviously the United States is born and
kind of bred on freedom and so I think
that the second you get into the police
enforcing anything that there's a lot of
social unrest possibilities that
happened and so I think that'll be kind
of a last step you know measure for them
so we'll see there let's see what else
green light to print 20 trillion yeah
look I don't know how much right now the
Fed's balance sheet is at four point six
trillion it went up about three hundred
fifty six billion dollars last week I
think that they're gonna have to add at
least five trillion dollars to kind of
even have a chance at stabilizing this
and getting us back to a recovery
process if they do that that means the
Fed's balance sheet would have to at
least double right there's many people
who think it's more than five trillion
some people think it's ten trillion 15
20 trillion is this person asked I I
don't know exactly what will happen but
but I definitely don't think it's one or
two trillion and even if it was only two
trillion you're still getting a 50%
increase give or take in the Fed balance
sheet so I just think that we just
haven't seen stuff like this before
and people just gotta pay attention it's
just wake up right pay attention to what
is happening um and understand how money
works and how the manipulation of the
money is
not in your favor right the people who
are being bailed out for so are very
clear right now
the people who are being bailed out or
not the average American the average
Americans not getting bailed out it is
the wealthy right if you look at its
hedge funds think about that hedge funds
have gotten bailed out before the
American people just let that sink in
for a second
the US government bailed out hedge funds
be filled it before bailed out the
American people that's not a situation
that is good long-term for the American
people and so I think that we've really
got to understand how money works and
you got to understand kind of that the
system is not rigged in favor of the
little guy and you've got to understand
how to protect yourself how to get
insurance on your wealth and make sure
that you can actually kind of do the
things you need to do for your family
pomp broadcasting from a crack house I'm
actually at my apartment in New York
City and I tried my best to not let you
guys figure out where I live call it a
crack house that's fine
is there a Bitcoin ETF I don't think
there's a chance that a Bitcoin ETF gets
approved this year maybe not even next
year I mean people just got way too many
other things going on the market
volatility etc so we'll see what happens
but if I was a betting guy I would bet
on it not happening this year for sure
joke locusts yo shout out to Joe Joe's
on here he's done a fantastic job of of
helping me get all of this video stuff
working so that while we're in
quarantine we can keep bringing you guys
content yes I got off dial-up internet I
finally have a ethernet cord I'm ready
to rock and roll we can live stream and
everything so shout out to Joe there
let's see what's my view on this global
crisis how to save the value of the
money that's being earned so hard over
the years it's amazing if you'll give us
your vision and advice yeah again I
think that right now in a deflationary
environment dollar will strengthen
assets will go down over time that will
switch to an inflationary environment
when that happens you want to have kind
of real assets you know or other assets
than the dollar so whether that's
equities commodities I think ever all
asset prices will rise when we get into
that inflation inflationary environment
so you want to
make sure that you're ready for that
when that happens let's see what else
here keeps put your questions in the
comments I'll try to get to as many of
them as I can how would the economy
behave during this crisis bitcoin was
the standard no Fed printing money but
market going down no banks dumping the
market neither yeah
so I think that's a good question like
if we were on the Bitcoin standard how
would the markets you know kind of act
the short answer is we don't know right
but I do think that what we do have is
historical examples right Kalyan Long's
been preaching for a long time about you
know previous economic crisis where we
were still attached to the gold standard
there was some sort of recessionary or
depression area type event the
government did not intervene but we were
allowed the market cycle to kind of
quickly play out bad companies went away
good company stayed strong
you know people lost jobs they were able
to get new jobs etc and the market was
able to correct itself very quickly
because that's the other thing that's
going on here right this is really
important to address which is let's take
the airlines or the the best example to
use so we literally have a entire
industry that has spent forty five
billion dollars on stock buybacks right
and before I get into the airlines let
me explain stock buybacks for a second
so I didn't interview the Med Weber med
did a fantastic job explaining the stock
buyback issue so previously what
somebody would do is if they had a lot
of cash they would issue a dividend to
investors over time there was through a
bunch of tax laws a more efficient way
to return kind of value to investors
rather than issue a true dividend was to
do a stock buyback right take care of
the market and your earnings per share
goes up stock price goes up and so a
stock buyback is just a more efficient
way of delivering a return to investors
than a traditional dividend right it's a
pure tax component that's okay there's
nothing wrong with doing that right med
would even argue that that is the job of
the executive team is to return value to
shareholders now where it gets dicey is
two things one executive compensation is
tied
to share price therefore executives are
personally incentivized to do stock
buybacks in order to pump up the stock
price because then they get paid more
money right so the incentive structure
is off as med did a great job of
explaining that's not a stock buyback
problem that's a board of directors
governance problem and maybe there
should be some rules there as to how we
actually structure executive
compensation and whether stock by stock
price can be tied to compensation or not
but that's not a stock buyback problem
that's an incentive problem that can be
addressed my problem is that's one bad
thing on the incentive side even worse
is when they're issuing debt - then get
capital - then do stock buybacks right
if you think of it that way now what you
have is a debt fueled stock buyback
program that is pumping up the price so
you're literally taking on more debt so
that you can then buy your own stock to
jack up your stock price so that you
personally can get paper money really
really bad situation so what ends up
happening is the airline industry hazrat
ismail forty five billion dollars in
stock buybacks over the last decade or
so they're currently asking for a fifty
billion dollar bailout right now there's
two ways to look at this one is hey that
forty five billion dollars got sent back
to shareholders in the sense of they
were buying back their shares and stock
prices were going up the other way to
look at it is if they had that forty
five billion dollars still in the
balance sheet they wouldn't need the
bailout right they would have stronger
balance sheets and so what you know both
sides have points that are valid but
what I do think that you're gonna start
to see here is you're gonna start to see
both executives and individuals in their
personal households say hey strong
balance sheets matter right I need to
make sure that I am always solvent so
that I then can profit the point of
business is to make profits you can't
make profits profits if you're insolvent
and so what I think we're seeing here is
there's a whole generation of people
who've been running companies for the
last decade plus who said to themselves
I can make bad decisions and if I get to
the point of insolvency on a entire
industry basis we will get bailed out by
the governor
I just don't think that that's the way
it should work and so market cycles are
there to clean out bad companies right
if you look at a lot of companies right
now they're super over leveraged with
debt they in many cases right I mean
mark usko has been saying this for a
long time they don't even make enough
EBIT uh to service their debt so there's
over leveraged companies when you get
them work at correction they're supposed
to get washed out if you don't let them
get washed out what you then have is
just a bigger and bigger bubble you kick
the can down the road and then when you
do get the final market correction it's
really bad so think of the market
correction we had in 2008 compared to
what we're going through now some would
argue that is really bad some would even
argue that the decisions we made in 2008
and 2009 have contributed to making this
even worse than it should have been
because we made bad decisions then we
kick the can down the road for ten years
right but going back to the market
cycles I think you gotta let these
companies kind of get washed out if you
end up being insolvent you should not be
allowed to continue running the business
and there's a lot of people who've made
the point on Twitter I think which is
very true here is if you get to the
point of insolvency it's not like the
assets go away the planes don't
disappear the employees don't disappear
what happens is those planes end up in
the hands of more innovative teams new
upstarts other competitors who are
better run organizations and therefore
capitalism and kind of free markets
allow for the strongest to not only
survive but thrive and the weakest end
up going away now I caveat all of that
by saying in that process there's a hell
of a lot of people that get hurt right a
lot of employees lose their jobs there's
a lot of carnage that's kind of left in
the wake of it and so I don't
necessarily think that it's a positive
thing in the short term I think is a
super negative thing but I do think
that's how market structures work and so
what we're starting to see here is that
the United States government is making
decisions between be being a fully
capitalistic society in which free
markets dominate competition dominates
etc and taking care of its people right
demographics have a lot to do with this
right if you look at the United States
demographics we've become older as a
country right the baby baby boomer
generation has kind of
continue to grow in age and so now we're
getting to this place where our country
starting to look differently and also
the response is different to these
crisis type situations and I think that
we're seeing that so what that goes back
to is I think actually what you should
say and one of meb's ideas change the
law so don't allow people to do stock
buybacks because it's more tax efficient
make them both just as efficient so
stock buybacks or dividends people will
start to dip it in cash but tell them
right this is my kind of angle on this
if you participate in dividend and stock
buybacks and you then want a bailout you
are not eligible for a bailout so you
can do this stuff but if you do it and
then you go and you want to bail out
later you're not eligible so if you
don't want to do stock buybacks or
dividends and you need a bailout you're
eligible now if you get executive teams
this kind of option right and let them
choose my guess is that many of them
will actually choose to continue to do
dividends or stock buybacks kind of
return value to shareholders and what
they'll know is oh I'm never gonna get a
bailout therefore I need to keep a
stronger balance sheet and therefore
rather than United Airlines which I
think spent like 70% of their free cash
flow on stock buybacks over the last ten
years maybe they would only spend 10 or
15 or 20 percent and keep the rest of
the cash on the balance sheet right and
they probably in a much better position
and so I think that's kind of it's an
incentive game we've got to understand
how this stuff works because once you
understand the incentives then you know
how to kind of change behavior so we'll
see that let's see what else uh there
hasn't been a free market in the price
of money for 107 years I don't know how
long's been but it's definitely not been
a free market any time soon
let's see do you think this Christ is a
perfect storm for people realizing the
real Bitcoin value that would drive more
adoption in countries will buy a lot of
Bitcoin store value how can this play
out yeah so one thing that to keep in
mind here that I think is really
interesting a lot of people haven't
talked about yet is ask the dollar
strengthens its actually other
currencies are weakening against it so
if you look at like you know USD the
Australian dollar pair or something like
that
Australian dollar falling off
compared to the US dollar right us are
strengthening Australian dollars
dropping in value and so all the sudden
what becomes really interesting is well
if I'm in a country outside of the
United States and my currency is
actually devaluing against the US dollar
I'm gonna do one of two things or at
least think about doing what it takes
they're gonna buy dollars I want access
to dollars that's the thing that's
getting stronger
or I'm gonna get out of my currency into
other assets right so Bitcoin etc
bitcoins 24/7 365 kind of globally
available just in an internet connection
etc becomes a really really big
advantage over other markets whether
that's equities commodities etc and the
ability to simply just log in to an
exchange upload some information
immediately buy the asset is a big
advantage so I think that has the dollar
strengthens and other currencies weaken
against it it wouldn't surprise me if we
see kind of capital inflows from other
parts of the world outside the United
States simply as people trying to
protect their wealth in an inflationary
hedge type asset I mean even if Japan
had zero cases the Olympics is all about
tourism so I don't see the point of aid
trying to go ahead with it yeah I think
if I understand correctly the Olympics
got postponed today so I don't think
that they're still trying to go ahead
with that but we'll we'll see what
happens there you know look that the
whole coronavirus thing or Cove in 19 I
think that what people need to
understand the United States and I'll
caveat all of this with it would not
surprise me if this is an unpopular
opinion I don't know
but basically we're faced with a choice
if we allow the coronavirus to run
rampant and we do nothing what we will
do is most likely we will overwhelm and
eventually collapse the healthcare
system right there's not enough ICU beds
there's not enough ventilators there's
not enough space you know all this kind
of stuff so regardless of how deadly you
think it is just the fact that people
need to go to the hospital or the
emergency room when they get this in
many cases ends up being you're gonna
overwhelm and eventually just collapse
the resources of the healthcare system
now trade that off with if we do what
we're doing which is essentially trying
to stop the collapse of the healthcare
system then what that means is we are
going to drastically negatively affect
or even collapse the economy right so
hey everyone go home stay inside the
economy collapses so we're faced with a
trade-off do we collapse the economy or
do we collapse the health
tear system unfortunately right in many
cases there's disagreement here right
it's not like there's one simple answer
between kind of all these various groups
of people everyone has their own opinion
what the United States is choosing to do
right now in the current form is we are
protecting the health care system
preventing collapse but the economy is
suffering because of it now there's a
lot of talk in in Washington from
politicians etc that I think Trump was
tweeting today maybe after 15 days we
actually reversed that and we go - okay
let's protect the economy and hopefully
we'll be past the worst parts of the the
virus scare and kind of the threat there
I don't really know kind of what happens
predicting the future is super hard but
what I do know is that we're right now
faced with do we allow the health care
system to collapse or do we allow the
economy to collapse we're choosing to
prevent the health care system from
collapsing and therefore the economy is
struggling and so it wouldn't surprise
me that in other places they're
realizing the health of their citizens
you know is much more important than the
actual economic benefit of certain
events
and so that's just a trade-off that
everyone in the world is going to have
to to choose to do let's see what else
one most central banks start buying
Bitcoin to transparently collateralize
their [ __ ] coins like they once did with
gold yeah so all of a sudden it starts
to look pretty interesting that Russia
China etc have been the largest gold
buyers for years now I think Russia has
been the largest buyer for a decade of
gold and holding in their reserves at
some point we were gonna start buying
Bitcoin right I don't know when it would
surprise me if they haven't already
right I think Venezuela may be announced
and again it's Venezuela and kind of the
the administration there is is shaky at
best if not frankly just kind of full of
[ __ ] but what they basically said is
they were gonna put I think Bitcoin in
aetherium or ether in their reserves I
don't know if they actually ever did it
but there was some announcement about
that it won't surprise me when other
central banks on countries go to do this
again they may have already started to
do this but when you get into a world
where the dollar is going to be weakened
because it has to be weakened just to
stabilize markets all of a sudden you're
gonna want other
sets water other assets that people can
hold etc I think gold and Bitcoin would
do well in that situation and so seeing
governments and central banks buy
Bitcoin wouldn't surprise me at all
actually I would expect them to do it
so we'll see how how that happens how
long till finance 1.0 is dunzo
yeah so here's a really big thing in my
opinion is it we are not going to see
the complete collapse of Wall Street and
the Fiat system and then the rise of
kind of this other system overnight like
it's not gonna be okay on June 1st
Wall Street collapsed on June 2nd
Bitcoin was the global reserve currency
instead what I think you're gonna see is
you're gonna see a multi-decade
transition from the current system kind
of a legacy financial system a Fiat
system etc to this new decentralized
global digital world that has Bitcoin as
that gold reserve currency but again I
think that's gonna take years and years
and years to occur and what you kind of
get is you get this compounding of
progress right it's kind of if we get 1%
better every day that compounds on
itself in over 20 years we end up being
in a much much better place than we are
today and and so I think that in that
kind of compounding you also get some
inflection points right things like you
know the Bretton Woods Agreement if you
look at the legacy system that was an
inflection point in the legacy system I
think that we'll have some of those
moments on this new system as well but
right now they're kind of both operating
in parallel obviously the legacy system
is much much bigger much more robust
much more liquid than the new system but
but if you look it's been 10 years and
made some pretty good progress wouldn't
surprise me ten years from now will be
look and say wow made a lot of progress
you know 20 30 years from now maybe we
got a shot at actually starting to kind
of surpass a legacy system but but I
don't take some time for that to happen
so we'll see what happens there what
else I'm gonna stay on for another 15
minutes here so let's see what uh what
else you guys have I don't know anything
about Canadian banks unfortunately so I
can't really comment on that do I think
China owning 80% of crypto destabilizes
the future of crypto yeah I don't really
understand this this thought process of
china owns crypto right yes there are
mining pools that that are in China
obviously yes there are miners in China
etc but Bitcoin the network is one of
the most decentralized things in the
world
there's miners all over the world right
and if you look at here in the United
States we've got incredible you know
hash power or hash rate coming online
and really what you're starting to see
is even more decentralization over time
on a geographic basis and so yeah I get
that China has been very kind of excited
about this been kind of out in front as
a nation etc but I'm of the belief that
Bitcoin and crypto is very global
there's people literally all over the
world you know what my favorite stories
to tell is plain and I went to Bulgaria
and I tweeted out and said hey I'll be
in Sofia anyone who's into a bit coin
and crypto I'd love to meet you meet at
this coffee shop 75 people showed up on
like a day's notice right and so it's
just you never realize kind of how many
people are into this stuff until you
sort of see some of those moments and so
it's really exciting to see butBut I'm
of the belief that this is a very global
thing and and obviously the kind of
monetary stimulus experiment that's
going on right now is only going to push
people further into into this world and
wanting to learn about it etc so do your
part helping educate them um let's see
what else
capturing stranded gas from fracking
yeah I mean look there's all kinds of
really interesting ways that people are
getting access to cheap power and so
renewable energy capturing flared gas
all that kind of stuff I think is going
to is already happening one but two will
continue over over time Tom W asking
reaps thoughts how do you see them
playing out the next six 12 24 months
look I think they're gonna follow the
housing and kind of real estate markets
obviously right and so right now you
probably don't see too much impact
as we get deeper and deeper into
liquidity crisis you're gonna see more
kind of consolidation there you'll see
some fire sales motivated sellers etc
and then you'll see the recoveries just
like we've seen in the past and so the
whole thing about these kind of
financial crisis is it's usually not
different right you you get the same
panic and fear you get the same
liquidity crisis you get the same kind
of monetary stimulus response you get
the same performance from assets time
and again and then you get the same
recovery over time and you reach
all-time new highs on the other side of
it so I think it's just really important
that people kind of keep their emotional
discipline they keep understanding how
important it is to just kind of remain
calm breathe remember we're gonna get
through this understand the decisions
you make today are actually going to
have an impact in the future you know
one of the things the best lessons I've
ever learned in investing is the day you
buy the asset is the day that you
determine the return that you get right
and so if you're able to buy assets for
less than they're worth obviously you're
gonna make a pretty attractive return
and I think that people just got to
remember that you know there's two ways
to look at kind of deep draw downs in
prices that there's obviously the way to
look at it is oh my god I'm losing money
and prices are dropping or there's the
way to look at opportunity and say hey I
can buy something that is now 30 40 50
percent cheaper than it was two months
ago but it's the same asset right you
know one of the things about equities
that actually is important to kind of
call out here is and Mark was walking me
through this and if I was really the
point is there's a lot of people so take
United Airlines for example I think they
did last year
six point five billion dollars in EBIT
uh but right now their market cap as of
last week was five point seven billion
so you could look at that back oh my god
their market cap is lower than their
EBIT uh well kind of but that was 2019
me but uh this year they had such a
massive drop-off in revenue that EBIT is
not gonna be anywhere near six point
five billion right I actually think that
they went from ninety-one percent
occupancy on all their flights or
something like that I just read to about
twenty four percent and so what ends up
happening is that company isn't so much
quote-unquote on sale
the market is just repricing what the
company is now worth based on the
revenue they're gonna make this year and
so what you've got to really try to
understand here is and not get caught is
using the analysis of historical data to
make an assessment on current value
right
you've gotta get access to some kind of
information in their filing successor to
understand what does it look like their
performance this year so I can
understand what the company's worth
today versus what they did in 2019 but
but I think Reid's is another example of
that right especially you know take a
commercial real estate
type trust all of a sudden what happens
if the tenants aren't paying right I
don't understand enough about the
intricacies of the various REITs but
that all that type of information
becomes really important because it's
one thing to have the stock price and
have that go down but but also
understanding well did the value of the
assets actually change right now and how
long is that sustainable will the value
actually recover in the future and if so
it's just the appearance of the value
changing but actually that the true
value hasn't changed all that needs to
go into the analysis I think in order to
really determine what assets you buy now
and kind of wait look at um so let's see
what else here if feel that many
populations are not disciplined enough
to be productive at the same time as not
spreading the virus so is either so it's
either one or the other
yeah look I tweeted today you know if we
want the American economy to recover the
best thing we can do is put American
workers and businesses back to work
right and you know a lot of people kind
of all freaking out like oh you do want
the virus to spread I think we after
understand is the world is not black and
white we don't have to make our
solutions black and white so we don't
have to say 100% of our workers need to
go home or 95 percent of our workers
need to go home or everyone goes to work
right there's all kinds of kind of
solutions that operate in the gray zone
that can allow the economy to at least
not completely shut down and have 25 50
% drops in GDP but at the same time kind
of tamper down the
spread of the virus and so I think that
yeah I'm gonna write about that for
tomorrow so you guys can kind of read
more intricate thoughts there but I
think that's really the key to this is
we don't need a black-and-white solution
but we probably need is something that's
a little bit more in the gray something
that's a little bit more nuanced and
that's how we get the American economy
back but it's also how we continue to
kind of slow down the spread of the
virus and also prevent the overwhelming
of the healthcare system so see a global
debt at 1 quadrillion by 2028 although
that it would be funny previously
there's a a chance that you're not wrong
so I'm gonna go there Fed has the next
stage of the plan digital wallets every
American to be used as debit cards top
that monthly by the Fed the Treasury
pays by buying two very expensive
platinum coins monthly as gold or silver
dead yeah so look that the whole idea of
2 1 trillion dollar platinum coins is is
one hilarious but two very real I mean
it's in the congresswoman's proposal and
so we'll see what what happens there
with that said there's a lot of
questions how as they introduced a
stimulus how are they gonna get the
money to people right I think in that
congresswoman's I'm forgetting her name
I apologize but in that congresswoman's
proposal basically everyone would get a
debit card it would come with $2,000 it
would be pre low it would be reloaded
every month with a thousand dollars
every month until the crisis ended plus
12 months or 12 months after the crisis
then they would stop doing them
newsflash if they start doing that type
of stuff I don't think they'll ever stop
so it's kind of like once you get hooked
right many you know I calls the stimulus
addict it's just like a crack addict
once you get on and you get high you
need another hit and get high a second
and third and fifth and twentieth and
132 hundredth time you need more crack
same thing with an economy that's
addicted to stimulus right we're seeing
it now in 2008 we need 700 billion
dollars to start well now we're talking
in the trillions right and by the time
we're done with this something is going
to be you know 5 10 trillion and so I
think that the second they start giving
people money whether it's on these debit
cards or they give them a digital wallet
somehow you know send stable coins or
whatever that the functionality is with
a mechanism you know I'm of the mindset
that we won't stop and it would just be
an everyday thing because these
emergency situations allow them to kind
of make giant leaps of innovation that
are hard to rollback afterwards now what
I will say is innovation can be good or
bad right it's still innovative but it
could be good or bad so in this case I
think most people will look at this as a
non negative meaning that it's not
really hurting people it's actually
trying to help people but if you look at
things like I think it's the DOJ just
asked for the right to hold people
indefinitely right you know you got to
kind of keep attention you know and be
really alert in these times because what
you get is you get the distraction of
right now a health crisis and a
financial crisis but are we going to see
civil liberties encroached on at the
same time basically because in the time
of emergency we need special powers and
then those special powers never get
rolled back or we never return to the
norm I think people need to stay really
really alert right now and we've got our
hands full right as a country as a as a
population the government and this is
not just an American thing this is
across the world people have to
understand there's a health crisis and
there's a financial crisis and they're
happening at the same time and it's a
really just kind of wild weird time to
be alive but that's where we are today
and so you know stay alert and let's
make sure that we don't get civil
liberties kind of encroached on in the
meantime all right let's all take two
more questions and that I'm going to a
run there's Domino's here now so that
means I gotta go eat u.s. paper dollars
in gold or disappearing I haven't heard
that so I'm I'm not uh I'm not really
sure Oh James Saul's what's up man can
we get our stimulus checks in Bitcoin
look I think that it's unlikely that
anyone's gonna be paying in Bitcoin
anytime soon a stable coin look it's
probably gonna happen in the next 12
months but at some point in the future
it would probably be cheaper and easier
for them to give folks a digital wallet
be able to
lock up your ID there and kind of you
know verify who you are and then they
basically are able to send you a you
know a digital dollar of some sort
whether it's backed by the Fed or the
Fed participates in it or it's a private
you know initiative I do think that
stable coins and a digital dollar is on
the way so the big question is just when
does it happen and and is it the United
States or somewhere else first
so we'll see we'll see how that happens
let's see I'll take one more question
here how government yeah so alright
there's a bunch of questions around like
should a government just print a bunch
of money and go buy Bitcoin right the
whole idea would be it the cost of
printing money is very low if Bitcoin is
gonna be so valuable why don't I go do
why don't I go buy a bunch of it I don't
think it's a bad idea right if you're a
government and you are losing faith in
or belief in your fiat currency and
you're going to end up you know kind of
driving it to zero overtime be cut
through devaluing it and printing more
why not accelerate it but have the
parachute right I continue say bitcoins
like a parachute that's masked as a
adrenaline rush because it's so volatile
but if you need the parachute prints a
bunch of money and go buy Bitcoin of
course that makes a ton of sense and you
know for a government to print a couple
billion dollars I don't think it's a big
deal so it surprised me
to see somebody do that and you know I
don't think in the United States
something is gonna be a superpower the
world I think it's gonna be kind of a
smaller more nimble country that really
kind of buys into the idea of
cryptocurrencies and sees no other
option
but we'll see there and then that also
you know it really brings me to this
idea that in these times
you know there's just a lot going on and
so as you interact with people I just
want to close out and just say there's a
lot of people that are being hurt right
now I think for most people on the
stream and for me you know we're
thinking about kind of the more macro
economic impacts the financial system
monetary policy how
this is going to play out five ten 20
years from now etc but it's really
important to also understand that
there's a lot of people right now right
I mean there's there's people on this
stream right now who have lost their
jobs and don't know how they're going to
make rent on April 1st right and and so
my overwhelming message to people is
regardless of what's happening kind of
in this financial crisis and in this
health crisis we just need to be kind to
each other right we really really need
to understand that we don't know what
our neighbors are going through what our
friends are going through what our
acquaintances are going through and so
one of the best things that you can do
is just simply be kind right and whether
that is the person at the grocery store
the person at the local shop the
neighbor you pass as you're keeping your
social distance or just people that you
talk to online I think being kind is
kind of one of the easiest things to do
it's free and you never know when it'll
have a positive impact on folks because
you know again there's people on this
stream right now who've lost their jobs
and they don't know how they're gonna
make rent on April 1st and the last
thing they need is somebody being an
[ __ ] too right and it's just kind of
compounds the stress of their life right
now and so if you can't help people
financially if you can't kind of do
things that you know are kind of more
obvious in the material world the least
you can do is be kind so I hope that um
you know you guys kind of take that
message to heart and and help people to
to kind of have that resonate over the
next couple of weeks and months as we go
through all this but that's it for for
tonight I'm gonna shut off this stream I
may do some of these more often I
actually enjoyed and kind of hearing all
the questions and stuff if you guys can
go subscribe to the newsletter you can
go to pop subst a calm go download the
podcast tell all your friends and then
feel free to share this live stream with
a couple of folks and let's see if we
can we can continue kind of spreading
the good word I preached you guys all
listening and we'll do it again soon